Justin Timberlake is one proud papa
my son is everything JT gushed over his
little boy Silas on an episode of Ellen
airing Friday explaining how he and
Jessica Biel's one-year-old son is
already musically inclined he's got to
be some kind of crazy talent from you
yeah he well I mean he dances around the
house and that's it just dances around
the house I mean he's 18 months I don't
know they don't like I want to like sing
or something no no no no he he he keeps
up with all the words to can't stop the
feelin I love that I'm kind of crazy I
don't know I feel like I'm like that guy
was just bragging on his kid on national
television but but you're supposed to
he's pretty rad so does he really know
the wiser that I'm smart no he's kind of
smart you guys yes he did the pop
superstar also says his son is a big fan
of his new animated movie but he loves
trolls
he loves the movie I'm Justin told et
last month at the film's premiere Silas
can adorably recognize his character
because he recognized his dad's voice he
knows all the characters already he does
yeah it's crazy